des poules en papier mâché des fleurs à
l'aquarelle et des sculptures étonnantes
bienvenue à la 15ème édition darmanin
ils sont cette année une cinquantaine
d'artistes à avoir exposé leurs oeuvres
les 14 et 15 octobre à la ferme du mas
net de montigny le bretonneux
en fait ce sont différents types de
matériaux il ya des encres il ya des
pigments naturels
il y a des poudre de marbre il ya des
poudres de
du graphiste l'exposition attire depuis
deux ans des artistes internationaux
c'est le cas de christophe qui vient
pour la première fois présenté
l'allemagne et ses régions à travers ces
travaux je viens de kirsten c'est une
ville entre cologne et dortmund en
allemagne donc est vraiment au milieu
d'une forêt dans la région du sauerland
qui est vraiment très verte et où il ya
beaucoup de nature autour de notre ville
ce rendez-vous pour les amateurs d'art
contemporain est aussi un moyen de
récolter des fonds pour venir en aide à
des associations
donc toutes les sommes sont reversés
pour des associations qui ressent au
niveau de la maladie d'alzheimer
le handicap ou là où la maltraitance
pour information l'année dernière par
exemple nous avons eu un résultat de 4
mille euros c'est 4000 euros sont
entièrement reversés à ces
manifestations la pour cette quinzième
édition l'organisation du lion's club
récolte près de 6000 euros